our car experts matus and sasha are in
new york on top of the empire state
but they're building here for the views
they're here for the new york auto show
ford has a mustang on show up here on
the 86th floor it had to be completely
taken apart to get it up here
each part had to be brought up by
elevator it's precision work they didn't
bother with the engine as this car is
going nowhere it's sitting pretty in the
world's most spectacular parking spot
the auto show itself took place
elsewhere in the city and there as well
ford had a strong presence but our
experts were more interested in german
car makers
mercedes brought the new c-class along
but the highlight for matas is the
s-63-amg coupe
that messes
the new model exudes power and pace
mercedes tested the car on the famous
nurburgring track
without a gun mercedes amg boss tobias
murray says it can go around the north
loop in eight minutes that time
demonstrates the car's agility and
dynamism
the front of the car is dominated by the
three-dimensional radiator grille and
new front apron
special wheels were developed for the
new model likewise sporting the amg
badge
eye catchers at the back are the shiny
black diffuser and quad exhaust pipes
bmw also made waves at the show they
showed off their new compact crossover
suv the x4 built in the us
that's the x4 made in spartanburg and of
course building on the success of all
the other x products we've brought into
the marketplace over the last few years
this car is really set i think for great
success
the x4 combines all the typical features
of a bmw with the sporting elegance of a
classic coupe
but the car maker also introduced an
even sportier model the new m4
convertible it's kitted out with a three
liter six cylinder engine the numbers
are impressive with 431 horsepower and
550 newton meters of torque the car can
go from zero to 100 kilometers an hour
in just 4.4 seconds
volkswagen has gone a bit more down to
earth they're introducing the latest
model of the jetta currently the
best-selling vw
it's had a facelift and the grille has
been adapted to improve engine cooling
misha o'horn of volkswagen says his
company has done a good job on the
exterior by freshening up the design
that looks wider and deeper but also
more dynamic and sportier
and inside there are differences too
vw is particularly proud that they've
improved the car safety standards
sell better in the states than in
germany points out sasha volkswagen has
sold more than a million jettas over the
last year it's one of the most
competitive cars in america
volkswagen is big in china too and there
just happens to be an auto show in
beijing as well
it's time for the guys to head over to
asia
new york to beijing is a hell of a drive
so matas and sasha caught a flight
instead
now they're at the auto china 2014 with
a new volkswagen touareg
there's also a new midsize coupe concept
car it should give an idea of what
direction the company will take in the
near future
enjoys a great tradition in china with a
presence there going back more than 25
years the new midsize coupe was designed
by klaus bischoff and his team in
wolfsburg
it could shed some light on how the new
passat cc will look it's a little
broader than the current passat and
shorter than the new jetta with its long
hood and short overhangs it's
reminiscent of the sirocco too
the kids are certainly enjoying getting
to grips with the cars
mata says it's more like a family outing
here than a publicity event but that's
how it is different folks different
strokes
german car makers know how important the
chinese market is it's experiencing
major growth like no other country in
the world
sales figures for suvs are especially
strong
audi has latched on to this they've
introduced a tt off-road concept car
which combines the power of a sports
model with the extra space of an
off-roader
it's also a plug-in hybrid making it
environmentally friendly
says they use intensive filtration
systems to keep dust and dirt out of
their cars and stop them getting inside
in the first place that's particularly
important in a city like beijing with
its serious pollution issues it means
customers get some respite from the smog
when they get into their cars
the hybrid engine delivers 408
horsepower and can reach 100 kilometers
per hour in just 5.2 seconds and it uses
less than 2 liters of fuel over 100
kilometers
porsche had some beauties on show
there were premieres for two new gts
models
the new porsche boxster gts
and the new porsche cayman gtx
the new cars are at the top of their
respective ranges
by default
sales and marketing head bernhard maya
says both cars have greater performance
and torque than before
as well as special chassis and the
porsche active suspension management
system as standard both also come with
extra features
the cayman gts comes with 340 horsepower
and the boxster's stats are similar the
new convertible will go on the market in
germany for under 70 000 euros
both models will be hitting the streets
in may here in china and in the usa
german car makers are showing why their
success is set to continue around the
world
you